hello everyone and welcome back to
Simply learns YouTube channel the cloud
landscape is evolving at a breathtaking
pace and Azure is at the Forefront of
this digital transformation today we'll
take you on a journey that will unlock
the doors to one of the most exciting
and dynamic careers in the world of
technology in this video we are going to
explore the path to becoming an Azure
Cloud architect in 202 4 but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these videos
and find them helpful then consider
getting subscribed to Simply learns
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn also if you want to become
a successful Cloud expert and gain
handsome salary packages then look at
the wide range of cloud computing
courses provided by simply learn in
collaboration with the top universities
across the globe by enrolling in any of
these certification programs you will
learn to master the architectural
principles and services of the top Cloud
platforms design and deploy highly
scalable fall tolerant applications and
develop skills to transform yourself
into an AWS and asure Cloud expert so
what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now a year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses so
check out the link mentioned in the
description box below for more details
so let's start this video with what is
cloud computing cloud computing refers
to the practice of using remote servers
on the internet to store manage and
process data instead of relying solely
on your local computer it allows you to
access your files applications and
services from anywhere with an internet
connection providing convenience
scalability and flexibility for
individuals and businesses alike moving
ahead let's discuss who is an Azure
Cloud architect an Azure Cloud architect
is a professional who specializes in
designing implementing and managing
cloud-based Solutions on the Microsoft
Azure platform Azure is Microsoft's
cloud computing platform that offers a
wide range of services and resources for
building deploying and managing
applications and infrastructures in the
cloud as your Cloud Architects are
critical in helping organizations
leverage azures capabilities to meet
their business objectives and Technical
requirements so let's move ahead and now
we'll go through the roles and
responsibilities of an Azure Cloud
architect the first is solution design
Azure Cloud Architects design solutions
that meet an organization's needs they
assess business requirements determine
which Azure service to use and create
architectural blueprints for cloud
deployment second is infrastructure
deployment they are responsible for
provisioning and configuring Azure
resources such as virtual machines
databases storage and networking
components to support the designed
Solutions number three is security and
compliance ensuring the security and
compliance of azure based solution is a
top priority Azure Cloud Architects
design security measures access controls
and compliance protocols to protect data
and
infrastructure number four is
performance optimization they
continually Monitor and optimizes your
resources to ensure that applications
and services run efficiently maintaining
cost Effectiveness and high performance
next on the list is disaster recovery
and high availability Architects plan
for disaster recovery and Implement High
availability solutions to minimize
downtime in case of system failures
moving on to last roles and
responsibility is collaboration aszure
Cloud architect Works closely with cross
functional teams including developers
administrators and business stakeholders
to ensure the Cloud solution align with
the organizational goals moving ahead
let's finally discuss the road map to
become an Azure Cloud architect becoming
an Azure Cloud architect involves a
combination of education training
experience and certification the initial
step to becoming an Azure Cloud
architect is educational background
start with a solid Educational
Foundation in computer science
information technology or or a related
field a bachelor's degree or higher in a
relevant discipline is often preferred
moving on to the next step we have gain
it experience build a strong foundation
in it by working in roles such as system
administrator network engineer developer
or Cloud engineer this experience will
provide you with valuable knowledge of
it infrastructures and applications
moving on to the next step of a road map
the next step is learning Azure
fundamentals familiarize yourself with
the basics of of Microsoft azzure
Microsoft offers various online
resources and documentation to help you
understand the core concept of azure
services including virtual machines
databases networking and security moving
on to the next step the next step is
azure certification earning Azure
certification is crucial to demonstrate
your expertise Microsoft's certification
path May evolve over time so be sure to
check out the latest certification
requirements on the Microsoft learning
website or you can enroll for simply
learns as your Cloud architect Masters
program this program will help you
master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azure creating
and deploying apps in Azure and securing
data in Azure this program also includes
an Azure exam voucher that can be Avail
to appear for any one course candidates
with one plus year of work experience
are preferred to enroll in this program
so don't forget to check out the link
mentioned in the description box below
for more details moving on to the next
step of our road map we have hands on
experience gain practical experience
with Azure by working on real world
projects create and manage Azure
resources deploy applications and
troubleshoot issues practical experience
is invaluable moving on to the next step
of our road map at number six we have
building a portfolio document your
projects and accomplishments having a
portfolio that showcase your Azure
architecture and implementation work can
be beneficial while applying for a job
moving on to number seven we have
Network and and stay informed join
azzure related communities attend
conferences and follow blogs and forums
to stay updated on the latest Azure
developments and best practices Azure
evolves rapidly so staying informed is
crucial and the last step to become a
master Azure Cloud architect in 2024 is
continuous learning Azure and Cloud
technology evolves rapidly stay up to
date with the latest Azure developments
and regularly update your certifications
to maintain your exper
last but not least let's discuss the
salary of an Azure Cloud architect in
2024 according to glaso the average
salary of an Azure Cloud architect
working in the United States ranges
between $100,000 to $200,000 per anom
and in India the salary ranges between
rupees 16 lakhs to rupees 18 lakhs perom
with additional cash compensation
ultimately it all comes down to the
skills you possess and the company you
are working for the these figures are
only the average number so remember that
the path to becoming an Azure Cloud
architect is not fixed and your journey
May varry depending on your background
and career goals it's essential to adapt
and learn continuously to stay
competitive in the ever challenging
field of cloud computing so with that we
have come to the end of this video on
how to become an Azure Cloud architect
in
2024 we hope you found this video
informative and helpful you should now
have a good understanding of all the
skills required to become a successful
Cloud architect so if you're interested
in learning more about different
Technologies plenty of resources are
available at simply learn you can also
check out our website for more
information on different certifications
so thank you so much for watching we'll
see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got got you covered explore
our impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here